[Music]
are you writing a novel on twitter
that's what i heard you're writing a
novel on twitter yeah it was going on
twitter and i right before that i
thought you know i used to write little
stories for myself for no reason like in
high school and stuff and then i thought
why don't i just write a novel on
twitter so i started writing the story
about a boy named harold in elementary
school and he was this and this happened
two sentences at a time just two
sentences at a time yeah yeah and then i
do know wouldn't do it for a few days
and i'd do three of them then i wouldn't
do it for a few days and i that i didn't
do it for a year
and then i started right in right and
back in and people leaving messages
saying my god someone he doesn't know
what this thing is for he needs to be
putting jokes on here this stuff is
perfect for this kind of humor what is
wrong with this guy someone should
explain it to him
so you've been how long
how long is this novel by now it's 1500
pages
1500 pages
if like there's one word on each page
[Applause]